- I love all the people
protesting Facebook on Instagram.
We prove as humans all the
time how we think about privacy
which is, we love to talk
about it, but we don't fear it
as much, because the underlining issue is,
the amount of bad things
that happen to the health
and wellbeing of our family,
or having our money stolen
is extremely far and few between.
- [Emily] You bought
Facebook stock on the back
of this drop, how much
did you buy, and why?
- I bought a couple hundred
thousand dollars worth
of shares, I bought
some more this morning.
Because I'm a long-term believer
in the stock and I don't
think there's gonna be a
lot of moments over the next
three to four years, outside
of macroeconomics, that
I'm gonna be able to take advantage of it.
I don't tend to buy a lot
of publicly traded stocks.
My original Facebook came
pre-IPO but, when it got hit
when all the Cambridge
Analytica stuff happened
and Mark was on trial I bought a ton.
Then obviously off the missing
numbers or news recently,
I've been buying up a little bit more.
Mainly because I think in the
next four, seven, nine, 13, 26
years it's a good buy.
- So, it's interesting,
then that is a big bet,
Roger McNmee, early Facebook
investor, who I'm sure
you know has been out there
very publicly critical of Facebook.
He compared Facebook to
Phillip Morris to me,
in terms of Facebook's
negative impact on the world.
What about concerns about fake news?
What about online hate? What
about concerns about privacy?
- I think there is a stunning
non-conversation about
taking on some sense of
responsibility, meaning sure
but choosing CNN or Fox or MSNBC has
as many dynamics as what
you're seeing in your feed, and
then more poorly what you're
choosing to consume as real.
I mean to me the thought that
Facebook is any different
than Twitter or Instagram,
which obviously they own,
or websites or a million
different ways we consume
is kind of laughable and
silly: I mean visa, and target,
and the American government
itself has had breaches
of information far more dramatic.
So, (clicks tongue) I
understand the concept,
but I think making a
jump from Phillip Morris,
which systematically
spent lobbying dollars
and tried to pay off politicians
for four to five decades to
suppress information, is an
awfully big jump by that person.
- Okay, but what about
profitability versus privacy?
Will one always trump the other?
And can we actually trust Facebook?
- I have no problem trusting
Facebook any more than
I trust any other company on earth.
Profitability and privacy
is kind of funny to me.
We choose to do convenience
over profitability
every day of the week.
And privacy, I mean
the way we pick privacy
on a pedestal is almost
nonexistent in our actions.
Every person watching this
right now gives up privacy
every day for convenience and speed.
Whether it's gonna be Amazon,
Google, or Apple, or Facebook,
or any of these companies
that sit as a layer on top
of the internet, we have
shown through our actions
over the last 30 years, and continue to,
with the usage of Instagram and others.
I love all the people protesting
Facebook on Instagram.
We prove as humans all the time
how we think about privacy,
which is we love to talk
about it, but we don't fear
it as much because the
underlining issue is the amount
of bad things that happen
to the health and well-being
of our family or having our money stolen
is extremely far and few between.
- What about the forces
that may be bigger than us?
The fact that Russia tried
to hack our elections,
using Facebook, and there's
evidence that they're doing
it again to sew discord.
Has Facebook done enough to
prevent itself from being weaponized?
- Facebook, this network,
Fox, CNN, Twitter,
it's all the same game
where I think about it
from a macro, which is we make decisions.
Facebook or the Russians
didn't make us pull for Trump
or Hillary, so, I think the
information that people are
buying ads and running
them in our screens is
very interesting because,
if you look at the execution
of people that run political
ads, the cost of penetrating
somebody with a different
opinion versus one that already
reinforces your stance
is where this starts
getting far more interesting.
I think this is one of the
great examples in human time
of us not interested in accountability.
Facebook didn't make you a racist,
you made yourself a racist.
- [Emily] So let's talk about Twitter.
Because you use Twitter a
lot, we saw the same huge dip
on the back of Twitter
earnings and it's very clear
that Twitter is just not
in a high growth state.
They've hit a plateau,
in fact they actually
lost users over the last quarter.
The influences there, the
President of the United States
is using it as his megaphone
but it's not the next Facebook.
- No, but it was never the next Facebook
and the truth is Facebook
is pfft, all encompassing
with Instagram and who knows
what Mark and Cheryl and
the team is up to on their next M & A
or innovation gotwhats app.
It is not the next Facebook,
I assume it's not priced
on wall street in the same manner.
I will say this, if you look
very closely to Moon Pie,
which is a small snack brand,
if you look at Wendy's,
I will say the business world
is starting to understand
how to use Facebook to drive business.
We're working with Kraft
Heinz on Miracle Whip.
It stuns me how much
Twitter is the back bone
of driving sales at
Albertson's and Wal Mart.
So I will say that maybe
the width of attention
on Twitter is not growing to a
stock market's want and needs
but, the depth of
attention in the platform
and the ways to maneuver
in it and it's ad product.
I've been, over the last
three to four years,
quite critical and not excited
about Twitter publicly.
But I no question have seen
over the last six to 12 months,
a resurgence different
than the Trump effect
of just how much attention
is in the platform.
When you have attention I think
you have the ultimate currency.
It will be interesting to see
what they do with their OTT.
I think they should play in that space.
I think they were flirting
with that a year or two ago.
Again, I don't know how
earnings are done or how much
the street values things,
but I will say depth,
maybe not width, is emerging on Twitter.
- [Emily] The top five
companies by market cap are
Facebook, Apple, Amazon,
Google, Microsoft.
In 2007 just before the financial crisis,
one of them was a tech company
and that was Microsoft.
Is the market putting too
many eggs in the tech basket?
- Honestly, I want to be
very fair for the audience,
I think about things in such long term.
The thought of me understanding
the short term economics
of 90 day terms and numbers
that most of the viewers here
play on and the arbitrary
nature, and the fact that we're
playing financial engineering,
not actually building
businesses, in the macro, of course not.
We're not going backwards.
Tech companies will
continue to gain momentum.
Let me pull it out here, this
is where we actually live,
not here, so in the super long term, no.
In the short term, I have
no sense if the market
has overpriced these companies based on
what the numbers they can
hit over the next 90 days.
People aren't gonna be
watching ABC and NBC
over Netflix, right?
People are not gonna
be consuming newspapers
over Facebook, that is
only gonna continue.
We're just starting in that world.
Short term economics and
the way the street likes
to play, that's up to all of you guys.
The danger in a five, 10, 15
year macro, I don't see it.
The reality is we're only
heading in one direction,
which is technology doesn't
care about our feelings
or our short term
judgement, or Wall Street.
It just continues to advance
and humans are engaging
deeper and deeper and deeper
and will continue to in perpetuity.
- Let's talk about the long term when
it comes to Apple and Netflix.
You played a role on
an Apple original show.
That show unfortunately didn't last long.
Certainly not because of you, but Apple is
doing this original
content grand experiment.
Do you think they can
succeed where Netflix has
when they haven't shown an
ability to do so thus far?
- I think the sheer amount
of money that I'm hearing
they're throwing at it
makes me optimistic.
I spend a good amount of time in Hollywood
and Silicon Valley and Madison Avenue.
You get a real sense, I
think the sense, if you talk
to any of your Hollywood
friends, production
and agents and things of that nature,
is everybody understands
that it's an Amazon, Apple,
Netflix, Hulu, and who's
the next OTT, Facebook,
kind of world, that the
networks are in deep trouble.
Even the cable providers,
even with mergers, the
sheer dollars that these
internet companies are gonna
throw at content, the NFL rights.
It's gonna be an Amazon,
Google, Facebook, Apple world.
And then, kind of
fighting for that, so yes.
I think that programming the
IP is what matters in the end.
When Apple, not if, has its Breaking Bad,
or Orange is the New Black, or NFL,
that it will suck people
in because of the IP.
It's the same way that
so many more people watch
Hulu and Amazon than a lot
of people thought they would
24 months ago, predicated on just one hit.
- I know you say you're not
an expert on short term market
dynamics but we're all
watching Apple and Amazon
in this race to a trillion dollars,
Amazon sort of coming from behind.
In the big picture do you see more
potential in one company or the other?
- In a substantial way.
I think the Delta between
Jeff Bezos and Tim Cook
as a 2018 CEO is unbelievably substantial.
I would bet every day
of the week on Amazon.
- [Emily] Why?
- Because I think Jeff has
just shown so much more ability
to navigate the end consumer's attention,
which I think is the
ultimate value in society.
I think that Tim A. Is an incredible guy
and I like a lot of the
things he as a human
and the company is trying
to push to stand for.
But he's been the CEO now
what, seven, eight years.
I'm not sure you can
help me with this but,
I mean what, ear pods?
I have not seen Apple win in voice
the way they should have with
the lead they had with Siri.
The home pod's still not out there.
We have not seen them
win an original program.
It's now been 24, 36 months
that cat's been out of the bag.
There's been no hardware
innovation outside the ear pods
that has any blimp of anything.
All they've really done
is slowly advance things
that have been in place prior.
You know, at least the way
I think about the world,
I don't look at it the numbers
and the ways short term
and maximizing profit every 90 days,
the way everybody who watches this does.
In the long term, what
it means for consumers,
Amazon through a magnitude of things
has done a far better job of
mattering to the end consumer
and continues to gain leverage.
- You mention the Networks are in trouble.
I have to ask about CBS,
which is currently deciding
the fate of Les Moonves
after these accusations
from a New Yorker article about
crossing a line with women.
Should he stay or go?
- Well if he's guilty he should go.
- Even after such a long
and successful track record?
- Doing the wrong thing is
always the wrong thing Emily.
You're only as good as your
last at bat or the truth.
We now don't look at Cristopher
Columbus the way we used to
after we looked carefully
in all the things he did.
So of course.
I'm very aware, listen I
love winning in business too,
everybody who's watching does,
but if you're a human being
that's willing to look
the other way for money,
you're not a good human being.
- So Gary, you've launched
a new media mens-lifestyle
grand focused on the intersection
of entrepreneurship and pop-culture.
You say there's not gonna be any walls.
There are no walls between
editorial and advertising.
What's the vision here?
- 18 months ago I bought purewow.com.
I have VaynorMedia, the
holding company's VaynorX,
VaynorMedia's the agency,
Madison Avenue madmen.
Purewow and 137 PM is the publishing side,
the hearse side of things.
To me, if you really look
at what the BuzzFeeds
and the vices and the refinery
29s did a half decade ago
is they kind of created publishing 2.0
where they started to do creative work
for clients instead of
just buying commercials
on TV networks or in magazines.
The branded content world
started to emerge, and you saw
those crazy evaluations for
a lot of those companies.
I think the continued
evolution of making content
and getting people to see it contextual,
that brings the Proctor &
Gambles and the Coca-Cola's value
is what's going to happen in publishing.
We continue to try to innovate
on creating original videos
and apps and event marketing.
Things to help clients sell
beer and makeup and deodorant.
- Last question, how are
all of these dynamics
that we're seeing in
social media companies
impacting your investment strategies?
What is hot right now and what is not?
- A couple ways to look at this
for me, it's just real life.
Facebook and Amazon are
the two stocks all in
that I believe in, in a
five to 10 year macro.
As long as Mark and Jeff
are running those companies
I'm blindly in belief
of how they'll innovate
around voice AR, you
know, machine learning.
They just are CEOs that
are willing to hurt
their short term economics
to do the long term equity
for having legacy over short term profit.
I think the most interesting
thing for this audience
and your show and what I
grew up with in the mid-2000s
on web 2.0 and social media is,
is there room for a
musical.ly or a Snapchat?
Where is this next social
network and are people scared
to do it because they're
scared to be a feature,
and Instagram, and Facebook,
Twitter will "copy" it
and slow it's growth like
we saw with Snapchat?
I'm most fascinated, will
there be another social network
on mobile devices, my
assumptions yes, but how?
Then more importantly,
my investment strategy
is massively being
effected by one core thing.
I believe voice devices
are the next iPhone
and the apps built on top
of the Google home, Amazon,
Alexa, and Apple pod are gonna
be the place where I come
out of retirement and
do early stage investing
the way I did with Twitter,
Facebook, and Tumblr.